- I'm a man.
I'm not crying, dog.
(laughs loudly)
I'm cool, I'm straight.
(upbeat music)
- [Man In Burgundy Shirt]
The worst drink of my life.
(laughs loudly)
I think it's like tequila and Ginger Ale.
Who made this?
(upbeat music)
- Cheers.
- I definitely feel it now.
- Yeah, me too, I feel
like an idiot, let's go.
(upbeat music)
- I have the hiccups
because I have the hiccups,
not because I have the drunk hiccups,
however, yes I am drunk
and I have the hiccups,
but I've had the hiccups all day.
- Do I need to take my Lactate pills?
(upbeat music)
- My favorite gift I got under the tree.
I am Jewish.
(laughs loudly)
- My sister got a dog one year.
It's beautiful, wonderful puppy
that I loved to play with.
- Growing up, we always had a cat,
which cats are fine, but I love dogs.
- My fiancee loves dogs.
Today, she posted a video of 50 pugs
running through the front
door of someone's house.
- Whoa!
- Look at this.
- Dog, if it's bugs, I'm
going to fight someone.
- Oh my God.
(laughs loudly)
Can I take it off?
- This is going to be
different than what I thought.
- Whoa!
(laughs)
- What?
- Ahh!
(crying loudly)
- This box is making noises like a dog.
(laughs loudly)
- Look, a dog.
Oh, oh my God.
- Oh my God.
- Can we name them.
- I haven't even looked at them.
I just needed to touch them so badly.
(speaking gibberish to dogs)
- Oh no, you just got neutered.
- Oh, and there's more.
God, what the hell?
- Don't drink my beer.
Now it's drinking beer.
- We get to keep them right?
- Yeah, that's the terms of the video.
That's what I was told.
- So this video was
originally supposed to be
drunk guys eat holiday foods.
We're supposed to eat these things?
- [Man In Plaid Shirt] Oh,
don't shiver, don't shiver.
Don't, oh no, don't shiver.
Shh, shh, shh, okay, don't shiver.
- Okay, get these, they're all,
don't fucking tell me that.
- You guys fooled us in
the best way possible.
I thought I was going to
get to eat delicious food.
- Are we not getting to get food?
- Oh, that's weird, oh jeez.
- And I think that, if
your kid wants a dog,
you know, that's a way to
get them to love Christmas.
- I want to steal all of them right now.
- Do not ever let this moment end.
- Merry Christmas.
- No, what's going on?
- [Man In White Shirt] Hey,
what are these guys doing?
Oh, they're playing!